okay episode I don't know of travels and
such boogie board in addition I'm here
with Paul dankey and Sean Greene to LA
legends and I'm just merging around some
real chill Wednesday morning traffic
Jesus love that truck
[Music]
mid-november what better time to get in
that water so we're going to get some
wetsuits right now and then we're gonna
boogie it up at San Onofre state park or
Beach whatever the Frick it is I'll be
honest I've never worn a wet suit dude I
can't wait I don't like the way you look
I had some cool buds when I lived in
Huntington Beach who were good at
surfing and when I would go with them
they'd take me not to the pier later
Timmy Toledo we're like the waves were
small and it was for boogie boarders or
whatever and one of them was you know
he's he's a real nice guy that would
also beat the out of the other and
some dude like I don't know what I'm
doing
surfing is like 9 foot board I like you
know paddled in front of somebody and
the dude was like learn some
goddamn etiquette and then my buddy who
is good at surfing it was like why don't
you do the pier why don't you
get the out this you're a for
even surfing here I'm only here
because this guy doesn't know what the
he's and I was just like okay yeah
Nick tell them you don't need that you
don't need to put me down so much but
this guy is a dumb piece of
so I met these guys ran still run comedy
show out of a garage called the comedy
garage the comedy garage and it was
literally just the comedy correct
we couldn't get booked anywhere else so
for an L and I found a pallet behind the
Ralph's in Burbank and put astroturf on
it and said it was a stage brought in
Paul and then yet just started doing
shows in the garage yes it's a pretty
big stage by the time I showed there
we're talking about a double pallet show
yes and in palettes it was it was rad
like every show is free and also beer
was provided for not just the comics the
audience yeah well we prided ourselves
on always buying beer and never charging
yeah but your front a poor financial
decision oh no I've never made a good
financial decision aka this show that's
why I'm scared to introduce sports
gambling to Brooks because normally I
like to try and introduce it but Brooks
I'm worried I did it in I did it in
college and it just didn't get my blood
boiling until I got up there to where I
was like this is gonna hurt me if I lose
it yeah and that's why it doesn't matter
if you win or lose I remember one time I
went to Las Vegas didn't pack just just
flew there from LA it was like 80 bucks
or something and then I took my contacts
out and I put them in like little cups
I bought this like solution but they're
in cups and I like made a big deal to
him I was like these are my contacts
these are my contacts and then in the
night he drank them so and I have really
bad vision so I can't see
anything but I still want to gamble you
know like I'd put like money down and
then I'd be like what did it what was it
did I get them did it it was bad well
talking about a rock bottom's I went on
an insane drinking you know
NFL Sunday just getting blackout drunk I
had a flight I fly back to Burbank but I
needed money for a cab so I borrow $25
from my friend for the cab I start
walking out the casino instead I stopped
at blackjack I go on a crazy run get up
$600 lose all that again and I remember
I had this you know kind of rock bottom
where I saw the dealer had their
prescription glasses next to them and
I'm like oh man I bet if I grab those I
can take him to a pawn shop get at least
$40 I didn't do it like I got on the
Southwest flight did not stop vomiting
the entire flight the stewardess kind
enough to give me a garbage bag and I
felt horrible oh boy and then I walked
home from the Burbank Airport to the
comedy garage house I and I ended up I
of course left my keys in Vegas so I had
a break in through the window and I cut
my leg real bad and anyway I was
supposed to host the show that night so
that's like the last show I've missed
hey how's it going
we were just gonna be we're in some
wetsuits what's the urine policy in the
wet suits 100% great oh boy Sean you're
gonna look spelt in that excel we need
to just one leash okay for a boogie cuz
we're clearly can't surf I would rather
have fun we're only going for a day I
know the each other who begin we're
gonna boogie we're committed gorillas
learning yes no look dick draggers
[Music]
I love when you get this close to the
ocean and you see people commuting
commuting by skateboard practical
transportation oh I'm going to work I'll
take the skateboard I love that it's
also fun when everyone in a town is
cooler than you but not mean about it
yeah I think they're just like hey how's
it going like and you're like pretty
good thanks for talking to me like so
I'm pretty cool where I come from yeah
yeah you're not there a name go ahead I
have a friend who's in that girl a
really big band it's so big he won't
even say the perio it's pretty dance I
don't want it this is cool yeah you're a
good friend I had just seen Neil Young
bet and then the next night Bruce
Springsteen and like we were super
stoned at his house and there's a bunch
of cool musicians and stuff and I'm
trying to fit in a little bit I was just
like ah I just saw Springsteen he was
actually pretty rad like you I liked him
better than Neil Young and my friend he
was like hey man like we really like you
don't say like okay so we are set
up here the beach I don't know if you
know this about travels and such we
don't really plan too far ahead so beach
campsite full we got a nice power plant
yeah there you go cover the lines and
everything what a Vista yeah sometimes
people camp to get off the grid we're in
the grid we're gonna toss it to our main
man Paul dankey for a little Deng keys
den he's gonna show us how to put up a
hammock I'm I was born in a hammock I'll
probably die in a hammock and I think
it's important to know how to put one up
and we've got just this perfect area oh
right over here some would say enough
yeah you just try not to lay down over
and expose root that will shatter your
tailbone unfortunately that's what we're
working with
we're we're gonna go right over the root
here call that the Widowmaker yeah this
is in Dickies den you got to just kind
of move and shake with what you're given
no I I quit I quit Boy Scouts at a very
early age I don't know how to actually
tie it up what the thing is about knots
is what they never want you to know and
the big knot industry is you just keep
keep crossing them and eventually it's
not gonna fall apart it's basically all
knots are
just keep retired yeah exactly knots are
fake that's big knot okay now this is
this is hung up a little high if you're
drunk and you fall asleep in a hammock
this high you're gonna hurt yourself
okay
I feel oh I'm feeling alright there you
go this is great we got a tank eased in
this is a this is a come to Daddy moment
yeah I used to have a screen saver that
was a lady laying topless in a hammock
like that and her boobs hanging all the
way down let's say I let it run the
screensaver all the time you have two
daughters right this is before the three
kids all right so wet suits are
notoriously easy to put on and tents are
notoriously easy to get dressed in so
you want to knock it out Sean oh yeah
all right a lot of rustling in there
yeah I just put my foot through an arm
sleeve yeah I own one of these when I
was 22 and died to become a surfer did
you leave all of your clothes on just my
shirt because that's where the mic was
[Laughter]
friends are for yeah that's backwards
man so wetsuits clearly success nailed
it hop on this
a dying bit on the show one fish taco
one shrimp taco you have got a case or
no no worries thank you my boy oh yeah
hanging out the beach you got to do it
tacos Cheers thank you
Cheers oh it's numbers Todd Oh God
Paul your role is chairs hey guys you
know what eating fish tacos at the beach
with some of my best friends reminds me
of what's a my great new phone plan that
visible it's like a no hidden fees
monthly phone plan that's $40 a month
all-in that's taxes included that's
unlimited minutes messaging data
hotspots all at very very fast speeds
and this is on Verizon LTE which as you
know Shawn is America's favorite network
no the nation's best network not just
its favorite so favorite cuz it's the
best
exactly 100% and you might be like why
are you bringing it up now yeah this
feels like an animal it's not it's not
now this is the show pro bono it's not
an ad I'm just telling you because
there's a new party pay for visible that
you could sign up with other people and
right now if you sign up for visible
your first month there's only $25 but if
you sign up with friends it goes down
let's say you juice ein up with two
people that's what you and one other
person it's only $35 a month for your
phone plan that's why three people
that's three that's $30 a month okay for
the three of us you got another person
in on this say we had another friend $25
a month for your phone plan so next time
I'm hanging out with someone I go up to
him I go hey do you party yeah they know
we're getting an unsub visible 1,000%
and if you wanted to know a little bit
more about it you could like scroll down
in this episode and you know click a
link that might take you to a place
where you could get you know some deals
on your phone plan we'd be wonderful and
it might help you know us men
future travels in such episodes but it
has nothing to do with ads or anything
this is 1000% just a thing I love and I
am NOT being compensated for it visible
scroll down check it out
[Music]
the key with getting in the ocean is to
never check the temp Wellspring 10
there
[Music]
all right so for an appetizer
bacon-wrapped scallops this is a wedding
Oh baby I think we're gonna throw some
butter in that pan sear these guys yep
then cook some really great steaks I put
maybe three pounds of zucchini on here
there's same amount of course easily 12
people worth of Gore's hair for sure
gourds is the right word right yeah
they're gourds
you're right yeah I've never seen butter
catch on fire quite like that well
you've never seen a pro I've never been
in the back of an Applebee's but I can
only assume well they bring out that
giant skillet with the fajitas sizzling
this is probably the before shot when I
bring this out out I would say the pans
hot yeah we should figure out a way to
flip over the zucchini no I think I got
it
here you know you should be man a giant
knife as a spatula brush yeah oh boy
yeah yeah yeah there we go oh well you
guys wouldn't try these scallops
yes sure I feel like they might need to
cool for a second no anywhere near my
mouth right are you that's hot for even
that's too hot for even a jacket you
know just pop them take it oh yeah great
idea
life hack there Paul yeah where you go
we don't need to touch that oh damn okay
um look at these little devils that
looks delicious
those look great we're gonna cut these
bad boys up Oh baby trying to figure
this out a little bit you think it'll be
hot oh god I really want nice good yeah
it looks great
good evening everybody
whoa oh yeah
Oh baby that's really good all my you're
going to pixelate this this is
pornography yeah you can't show this
going into my body I love also eating in
front of people that haven't had dinner
yet
let's see you guys sorry for that the
crew eats better than us
hahaha they plan it you guys plan what
you bring they had lobster tail last
time well yeah they let us ruin one that
was nice of them yeah how did you ruin
it put it in the fire too long yeah
that'll do it
so why people in other countries hate us
we're ruining lobsters for webseries
they're right okay not just a webseries
a visible sponsor but six oh there
[Music]
oof still hot oh my gosh giant this has
been it's like Jiffy Pop but for Zuko
baby alright
that actually looks pretty good get in
there try it will look so warm oh that's
so that's a soft that's a soft kini you
just throw it on there for way too long
and then it turns into a suit I was
gonna say Stu almost a hearty stew
quality if you're not feeling
late-november energy with this zucchini
dish then you just yeah we just got here
now what we're gonna do is get ready to
season these steaks
we're gonna put some butter some RP some
red Pat red pepper on a steak all right
I want a little zip shake it in there
okay well everything bagel stuff yeah
that's a blow hole don't get shy with
that don't don't be shy with that
everything so we got some seasoning on
that guy putting it on there four
minutes each side flip them
don't love how stoned I got all right
we're gonna hang out a few more minutes
and flip I'd say four minutes each side
I don't know how long has been it's been
about a minute time is going really
really slow you said one either way
we'll look it up yeah so if I want to
see how to take well really nice cuts of
meat and make them look like hamburgers
just follow what I did throw them on a
700 degree fahrenheit grill forget about
time for a little bit here we go we're
gonna take a bite of this guy I'm ready
so we're gonna give us each a really
good slice yes it's so good okay yeah
probably though the more cooked of the
grill to be the smallest so if we can
see each one of us gets one of these
cheers it yeah sure cheers Cheers
little steak steak fry hmm there's more
I've got some char oh god that's so good
whoa who has this magical oh I was gonna
I was gonna blow your mind
blew my mouth I was I am Fire Magic what
the fudge you were like are we gonna
wait for the camera crew to leave till
you did this cuz this is really fun
night here we go
oh you just put the whole bag in yep
that's really neat I'll throw in a
different color I can't wait
great throw awesome and you can just see
the toxins going straight into the sky
Gail that thing yeah we're out in nature
this tree is absorbing all of it this
dangerously close tree
that's really fun you got one more right
throw that guy there's more more I'm
just gonna say it yeah go hard go
hard this is crazy it looks like magic
it looks like a Magic the Gathering like
card
Merlin's here you know yeah this is
super terrific honestly wild I'm see I'm
getting blues and greens Shawn what am I
missing what are their notes ours I've
seen blues them seen greens I've seen
oranges yep some extra orange they'll
actually be a little artificial yellow
in there it's tough to see that's really
ballsy to bring yellow to a fire magic
I'm sorry this is cool
done all right well we're gonna take a
nap or cheesy music you're right we're
gonna go to bed yeah I did we'll see you
in the morning I'm gonna make some
breakfast we had a great day
[Music]
[Applause]
you sleep alright pretty good yeah as
far as sleeping on a giant rock pulse it
in there in his boozy ass air mattress
and real pillow and I'm sitting there
with like a hoody just balled up next to
a rock so there were times where I
thought about like hey man this is the
wild I'm just gonna murder Paul and take
the air mattress but I let it go man in
honor friendship yeah well I decided not
to kill Paul for his air mattress it
would've really changed the dynamic of
this episode I looked over at one point
in the early hours of the morning as the
light was coming up and I just stared at
Sean sleeping for a while I was like
here's my here's my pal I too could
murder him you know I've got the pillow
for smothering right here I I really
enjoyed camping with Sean and Paul
they're great friends I didn't have to
think hard because literally the last
two people had texted with I go let's
just not dig too deep
I thought the surf shop was pretty
gnarly guy didn't give me the courtesy
of explaining how to put on a wetsuit so
I ended up like you know kind of look
like a huge so other than that I
got to say having be boarded and in a
few years and I have been up it
is the best don't surf it is really fun
you kind of look dumb and it also at a
few points is really scary you know my
wave catch percentage wasn't amazing but
I caught a couple big ones so we had
delicious Pedro's tacos shout - Pedro's
awesome while we ate him I just brought
up to Paul and Sean my new phone plan
completely unscripted visible one
monthly price $40 no fees I thought the
fish tacos were amazing they were fried
every fish taco dinner I tell people
whatever phone plan I'm currently on
it's always so great eating when you're
camping it's the best part of camping
food tastes better
smells smell better and those
bacon-wrapped babies they just melt it
in my little mouth
I almost forgot to throw the campfire
magic in the campfire I kind of got
distracted with the bacon-wrapped
scallops the steaks also I'm pretty sure
Brooks thought they could have been
drugs because he picked him up and got
really really excited I've never looked
at fire and thought this could be cooler
turns out it can be fire has been
up I had good time with my boys
Paul Philly Philly all right got him on
the shoulder
I got him both I love them both equally
I had a fun time camping right yep
success
come on just couple of guys
[Music]